sascha Alexeyev ax never goes anywhere
without her bag she makes a new
political poster for it every week and
takes it with her on her commute
whether it's sexism freedom of speech or
this call to donate bone marrow members
of teehee pickets the silent protest
movement take on any topic they think
needs public discussion in Russia sasha
was one of the first of around 80 young
women who started taking political
posters with them everywhere they went
and then sharing their experiences
online our goal is to create a
politically aware civil society the
problem in Russia is that everyone is
hoping for some kind of Messiah someone
who will lead us all to a revolution but
that won't happen you need a lot of
people normal people not heroes to see
themselves as political actors and
change something in today's Russia even
carrying posters on social issues as a
political act and voicing dissent is
getting harder according to recent laws
even peaceful protestors like Marvel
p.m. can be imprisoned for up to 5 years
Palpatine has been actively involved in
anti-government protests since early
2011 there's absolutely no freedom of
assembly if you want to organize a
political gathering or a protest then in
the majority of cases the authorities
won't give you permission as Russian
parliamentary elections approached Sasha
and Darya City Anka the founder of
ticket hope their posters will get
people thinking about politics as well
we don't have the resources the
government has we don't have access to
television
we don't have funding we're just trying
to do what we can and that means
changing things won't be a quick process
to process
Sasha wants her words to make people
think she hopes to change minds one
poster at a time